we've all lived in New York it was once
a great state it has become an absolute
disaster New York City is a freaking
nightmare under Eric Adams which is just
an extension of de Blasio hokel took
over nobody's ever voted for her she
loves lockdowns she would do it all
again here is Lee zeldin who just sort
of appeared out of nowhere in the last
two months and he's leading in some of
the polls right now my opponent still
can't finish the sentence you can't
expect her to ever fix it but New York
leads the entire nation in population
loss because
she actually got to ask this question by
the media a few weeks ago when she was
at Binghamton Airport she probably would
love to have a redo because she messed
it up that time for me you asked me why
does New York lead the entire nation in
population loss because their wallets
their safety their freedom and their
quality of their kids education under
attack so they're hitting their Breaking
Point they'll look in other states like
the Carolinas Tennessee Texas Florida
and elsewhere and they feel like their
money will go further they'll feel safer
and they'll live life Freer the state is
at a Crossroads we're at a Crossroads in
1994 when New York elected George Pataki
and we're at a crossroads right now but
as far as what happens with Kathy hokel
a one party rule for four more years
outsized power of self-described
socialists we need balance and Common
Sense restored to Albany
Carol I was super impressed by him I
watched the replay of the entire debate
it wasn't just that you know it's easy
to hit hocal because she's been so bad
it's like he's passionate he's honest he
also strikes me as a decent guy who
would pick up your pick your friends up
after school and take you to Burger King
or something like I think this is just
what New York needs I agree he's really
great even you know his primary
opponents like Rob astorino have been
openly supporting him and really pushing
him I think that's really a tell that
that they're kind of motivated to defeat
hokel and you know let bygones be
bygones
um yeah I think he's terrific and I
would love to see New York do the same
thing I know that a lot of people have
one foot out the door waiting to see
what's going to happen with this because
if it is hocal again if she gets you
know reelected and she can say look they
wanted me they wanted my policies they
wanted my ideas who knows what she's
going to do and you know winter is
coming coveted rates are going to spike
again because that's what covert rates
do in the winter in New York and she
could put the kids back in math she's
already suggested it she could easily
lock down schools she could do any
number of things that I think people
should be prepared for this is a really
important election for New York this is
a really make or break election for New
York and they should look at it like
that just to Echo what zeldin said there
they're giving me some numbers right now
so the population in New York in 2021
was about 19.8 million which was a 1.58
decline from the year before I mean
that's fairly significant John that
shouldn't surprise anybody right because
hokel even said we if you don't share
our values get going to Florida well
look at the four of us yeah yeah look I
mean they lost a congressional seat
Florida gained one but but I think Elias
I know Lee and Lee is is the guy you
just described real likable guy very
confident very well versed in the issues
crime is is off the charts and I can
speak to this one with authority I came
out of the police academy in 1993 under
David Dinkins right and crime was bad
but it wasn't this bad the criminals
weren't as bold yeah by the Numbers
there was more action crime because the
years of losing bodies in the NYPD due
to fiscal problems and having to rebuild
and liberal policies but because of the
world culture the BLM riots the antifa
riots Dave what I'm seeing right what
I'm analyzing through the lens of
experience and what I'm getting from the
men and women still on the job and Carol
I know speaks to them as well you know
via the post the uh the boldness of the
criminal is much different even under
dink crime was bad the cops had rolled
up we'd roll up in a more car they'd
still run now they spit at you they give
you the finger they make simulated uh
gestures like they're going to shoot you
I've never seen boldness in criminals
like this because they were emboldened
starting in 2008 by the Obama
Administration and they still are by
Democrats running these cities